L'évangile du doute ne demande pas que vous cessiez de croire,
mais que vous croyiez en quelque chose de nouveau :
qu'il est possible de ne pas croire.
Il est possible que les réponses soient fausses,
que les questions elles-mêmes soient fausses.
Oui, l'évangile du doute signifie qu'il est possible que nous,
sur cette scène, dans cette salle,
ayons tort.
Parce qu'elle soulève la question : « Pourquoi ? »
Avec tout le pouvoir que nous détenons dans nos mains,
pourquoi des personnes souffrent-elles encore autant ?
Ce doute me mène à partager que nous plaçons mon organisation,
MBAs Across America,
en cessation d'activité.
Nous avons congédié notre équipe et fermé nos portes,
et nous allons partager notre modèle librement
avec tout ceux qui saisissent le pouvoir de faire ce travail
sans attendre notre permission.
Ce doute m'oblige
à renoncer au rôle de sauveur que certains attendent de moi,
parce qu'il n'y a pas assez de temps et que nos chances sont trop minces
pour attendre des secondes venues,
lorsque la vérité est qu'il n'y aura pas de miracles ici.
Et ce doute, il me régénère,
il me donne l'espoir,
que lorsque nos problèmes nous submergent,
lorsque les chemins conçus pour nous semblent nous mener à notre perte,
lorsque nos guérisseurs n'apportent aucun secours à nos blessures,
ce ne sera pas notre foi aveugle —
non, ce sera notre humble doute
qui illuminera un petit peu la noirceur de nos vies
et de notre monde,
et nous permettra de faire entendre nos voix pour chuchoter,
ou pour crier,
ou pour dire simplement,
très simplement :
« Il doit y avoir un autre moyen. »
Merci.
(Applaudissements)